hello and welcome to the city of playing
Jerome here with white and goddesses
sign no I don't do that yeah funny 9 95
it's not it's not so terrible yeah that
looks pretty terrible i have to say but
cable team will see how to play here
it's maybe maybe this is too slow i
don't know
so let's let's get something going in
that's very very cheeky to take on c3
but yeah maybe you have to take on
before I mean
so interesting here Queen to h5 I can
also take there and give the check it's
also pretty bad this is also hanging
what if i take and play come to g form
what is still what's happening then i
can also check first g6g six Queens you
fry it also looks fantastic hmm ok let's
do that not not spend more time
e 6 hangs g7 hangs and the bishop hangs
on before
so he cancelled black resigns yes yeah I
take just take the bishop yeah Knight a5
is a borderline move I think but you
what you definitely cannot do is like
wasting even more time like with this d5
looks extremely risky open up the
position when you have nothing developed
and this is this is hard to believe the
computer is even a brutal here but ok
this is also winning really a computer
says winning yeah plus 1.5 it doesn't do
this though it wants to play d4 yeah
maybe this is stronger c4b force is very
strong in here you have this threat
which is terrible and if the night comes
back then a four I mean black has no
development here you form and now knight
c6 is still kind of okay here 96 I
wanted to take take Knight c3 done it
was yeah okay that that's also very good
okay so my play wasn't bad it was
something better checking this now just
want to develop as quickly as possible
and him I Queenie 2 is also very strong
probably probably they all win this is
janna also winning this should be 2 is
given by the engine it which is also
very strong it looks at this pond and
castles Queens you for is quite quite
deadly now that opening is too risky i
mean 95 it's still kind of playable but
then you have to make sure to develop
some stuff ok guys thanks for watching